Quantum physics doesn't make sense to me.
Well,
I've tried.
Tried really hard.
It makes about the same senses.
That definition you were just reading Spanish.
Exactly.
I'll go over it and over it again and get little chunks of it and that would
understand like sections of sentences.
Right,
and then it would have to try to put them together with the other sections.
It's hard.
It's tough stuff,
but one of the most important things,
I think it was the old war who said this,
I'm not quite sure,
but one of the members of the Copenhagen interpretation of quantum physics said
that basically a particle exists in many states simultaneously and it's not
until it's measured that a collapses into one stage.
That's one of the basic principles of quantum physics.
Well guess what,
Niels,
every particle is being measured in some way all the time,
all of its life by other particles that are basically taking its measure and
then responding.
Essentially.
Nothing is isolated.
Nothing is isolated in this particular cosmos.
You were talking,
I watched a video where you were talking about that there is essentially a
universal brain.
Well,
yes,
because you and I right now,
uh,
we're going to be talking to possibly out of your 500 words,
it's more like 1 million,
uh,
total viewers and listeners more than that.
So it's probably closer to three.
Yeah.
So we're going to be talking to let's say 100,000 of them or 200,000 of them.
Um,
and they're processing what we are saying right now there are bacteria in your
gut and mine who live in enormous colonies and enormous bacterial colony.
If you had it on the palm of your hand,
it would be the size of her hand,
but you couldn't see it.
Are you thinking of this while you're saying it,
are you thinking of that vast numbers of people that are listening and watching
or are you just relaying the information?
Like are you
cognizant?
Yup,
both.
Both.
Because I want,
remember Einstein gave me my marching orders,
right?
You have to take complex ideas and simplify them so much that anyone with a high
school education in a reasonable degree of on intelligence can understand them.
And I want to make good radio for your audience.
But once you,
what I'm trying to get at is once you have got an established in your head that
nothing is isolated,
that everything is connected.
When you speak,
are you aware when you're speaking that everything is connected?
I mean,
are you,
are you actually consciously thinking of all of these different minds taking
into account all these different mind blowing things that you're saying and then
applying them out in the world?
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
if you hear it coming out of my mouth,
that's what's churning around in my brain.
I'm just,
you're,
you're such a bright guy.
I'm just trying to understand if you are in the moment or if you're in the
moment,
as well as being consciously aware of the spread of information.
My obligation is to do both simultaneously.
That's my obligation.
That's what I assumed.
Yeah.
So at any rate,
so the,
the entropic theory doesn't make any sense.
The,
I mean,
look there,
I wasn't a bad,
right,
right.
So you would think I'm totally isolate.
I'm not,
you're not.
I'm not.
I mean,
once upon a time I wrote an essay about Descartes.
Well,
Descartes came up with the idea of,
I think therefore I am.
Um,
he took a retreat in Amsterdam.
He rented a second floor apartment and he was trying to isolate himself the way
that those particles are isolated with the short ministers equation,
the particles that were being drawn on Napkins in Moscow.
Um,
and so that he could strip everything away and find out what was the most basic
thing,
the most basic axiom and the most basic thing we take for granted in life.
And he came up with,
I think therefore I am now.
Think about this for a minute.
While he was trying to think this out,
he was needing a rubbery gum eraser with which he erased is inc he was sitting
on the second floor,
which means somebody had invented the architecture that he was sitting in and
the concept of the floor and the concept of beams that go across from one wall
to the other that were holding him up.
He was looking out the window and he was looking at the hats that the Amsterdam
men and women were wearing as they walked by.
And he was fucking the cleaning lady who he made pregnant.
So how isolated really was he
the universal mind theory this or this concept shouldn't say theory.
Um,
w the way you were describing it,
it's very interesting that there is no individual thought that essentially
there's,
there's lots of individual thought.
It's all connected to all the other people that are around you and all the
people that you've interacted with and all the places you've been and the things
you've seen and all the people that are constantly thinking simultaneously
around you that you're aware of
and the people that you're trying to influence because you're trying to
influence people all day long,
right?
If you want somebody to bring you a sandwich,
you have to get across that.
You want that sandwich.
And especially if you want somebody like a wife or an assistant to bring you a
sandwich and that's not normally what they do,
then you really have to work hard and influence going.
But,
but the,
the universe,
at least the living part of the universe and so far we only know of life on this
planet.
It's all interconnected.
Those bacteria I was talking about there in your gut.
They are making your vitamin B,
they are making your vitamin K,
they are making an awful lot of the things that you use to survive.
They're also making chemicals that influence your mind and your moods.
They're manipulating you.
So when you go down to the corner store to buy some chocolate eclairs and you go
home and you eat them.
In fact,
you can only digest a small portion of the chocolate ne Claire,
those bacterial colonies living in your gut.
They do the rest of that I adjusting for you.
So who's really going to the corner store?
Who's really the boss who's really driving you the vehicle of transportation?
Are these bacteria driving you down to the corner store so that you will feed
them the stuff that they love,
the or ours,
your will driving you to the corner store.
While the answer's a little of both,
a little of both.
Not as much of both.
I mean there,
there's this example of
there's this fungus and the fungus has a very peculiar lifestyle and I'm very
curious to find out how it got this lifestyle.
But it lives half of its life in an ant colony and half of its life and a sheep.
So when it comes out of the phase of that,
it goes through in the ant colony and is ready to go into the sheep,
it takes over the brain of an ant and it gets that ant to climb to the top of a
stalk of grass.
Why?
Because when the sheep come along to graze,
they will inhale the ant.
What you're telling me,
that a fungus can control the mind of an ant in ways that we're just beginning
to explore now this year and maybe last year,
a tiny little bit,
that it can actually be that precise in how it takes over the controls of this
site to one of those,
uh,
the fungus that gets inside those ants and the answer aware of it.
So they take the ant away because the aunt will explode and spray spores into
the air and affect the infect call.
I'm not aware of that one,
but it sounds cordyceps.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it,
but it sounds similar but,
but it's the real deal is okay.
Life on this earth functions the way that a beehive functions.
How does it be high functioning?
95% of the bees are conformist peas and they all go out to the hot flower patch
of the day and they mine the nectar and they have a public stomach in which they
can carry this stuff.
I mean built into them inside of them and they have these caring hairs on their
thighs and they carry pollen in those.
And when they arrive at the unloading bay,
there is an unloading bay and the hive.
if the unloaders no,
that the interior really needs pollen and nectar and they see you carrying that
pollen and nectar,
they stick their tongues down your throat to check out what's in your public
stomach.
They go wild with excitement.
When they discover it's filled with nectar,
they check out your thighs,
the caring hairs on your thighs.
They go wild.
When they see that you're carrying pawn,
they feel you all over with their antenna.
They are intensely excited when they are unloading you and that gets you
excited.
You feel like a rockstar because this is the same kind of attention a rockstar
gets.
So you go back out to the flower patch of the day and mine some more.
Meanwhile,
there are these lazy good for nothing.
Bohemian bees.
There are any way from 5% to 20% of the colony and they don't do a single useful
thing at all.
And so far as you can see,
they don't do anything to earn their keep in the colony.
Why?
Cause they're out doing loop after loop after loop and lazy eight after lazy
eights after lazy aid.
So they'll fly eight miles just following their whims,
following their whims.
I mean if you were their mother,
what would you say?
You're wasting your fucking life for God's sakes.
Okay.
Eventually you the conformist be start coming back without pollen.
And you're carrying Harris and without nectar and your public summer because the
flower patch,
that flower patch of the day has been thoroughly plundered.
And when you arrive at the unloading dock of the hive,
the unloading be stick their tongue into your public stomach empty.
Sorry.
They see you're carrying Harris empty.
They turned their backs on you so savagely that you feel as if you've been cut
dead and it finally,
I mean you can't believe that the old is not delivering anymore and it's not
giving you a paycheck.
So you keep going back to the same patch over and over again more slowly each
time until finally you give up and you literally crawl into the hive.
And Thomas Sealy,
the guy who's done most of the research on this,
calls you an unemployed B and you are as depressed as if you were an employee.
How do we know that?
Because your body temperature is down and you're crawling instead of walking and
you're begging for food from other bees.
Well,
you look for something to perk you up.
Now what a humans use a football game.
A movie bees used pretty much the same thing.
What does that mean?
They go to the unloading dock out of the 200 lazy good for nothing.
Bohemian be simply following their instincts.
Five have come back having found new flower patches and they are dancing and the
dancing excites you and they're dancing in competition with each other.
Some will dance 27 seconds,
some will dance 27 minutes and if you find the dance of one of those dancers
sufficiently persuasive,
it lifts you out of your lethargy,
gets you excited and you fly out.
She's giving a little in a little figure eight dance.
She is giving precise instructions on how to get to the flower patch and what
the headwinds are and what the tailwinds are and you pick up her message,
you fly out to the flower patch to that she has recommended and you check it out
for yourself and if you get excited about it,
you come back and you start dancing and ultimately the be who gets the greatest
number of backup dancers wins and you all go out,
all you can form us.
Bees were now unemployed.
Go out to the new hot flower patch of the day and the same pattern repeats
itself.
Now that's a collective mind operating on the basis of 20,000 independent bees
and the the living world operates and pretty much the same way bacteria are
using you to get them truckload a Claris.
You are using them to digest chocolate eclairs they are teasing our scientists
and to wild activity by threatening to develop illnesses that can bypass all of
our antibiotics,
which by the way are chemical weapons that microorganisms,
colonies and microsomal organisms used to kill and tire competing colonies.
We stole him from microorganisms so we didn't,
didn't met them antibiotics.
So the scientists are very worth fact that the bees are,
that the bacteria are getting ahead of us in research and development and are
beginning to develop techniques to get around all of our drugs.
So they are researching their ass off.
So is there any common brain that links the bacteria to the scientific
community?
You bet they're competing with each other and in the process of competing with
each other,
what are they doing?
They are both creating new options for all of life.